[Music]
these stories have been told thousands
of years ago and it is only now that we
realized that they were actually true
from real-life monsters to true gifts
from the gods
you'll be surprised to know that the
Greeks were not so crazy after all just
wait until you see a real-life Medusa
that can end your life just by looking
at it if this is your first time
visiting our channel don't forget to
subscribe and please give this video a
big thumbs up today we're showing you
ten ancient Greek myths that turned out
to be true
the mermaids in Greek mythology mermaids
and sirens were irresistible sea
creatures half fish and half woman with
the sweetness of their song they lured
sailors to a terrible fate in Homer's
Odyssey the Greek hero was advised by
the sorceress Circe to put wax in his
ears so he wouldn't be able to hear
their voices however he wanted to know
if he could resist the temptation so he
tied himself to the mast
while the members of his crew were deaf
when he heard the song he begged them to
let him go but they just waited until
they were far away from the sirens
instead and as a man had the strength to
escape them the sirens flung themselves
into the water and perished but Odysseus
is not the only one who saw a mermaid
John Smith better known for meeting
Pocahontas met one too he described her
as a green haired woman swimming in the
water who was by no means unattractive
she dived into the water and this was
when he was shocked to see that she had
a tail Smith is not the only one who
claimed that he saw a mermaid but these
men are all missing something
evidence however if you want to see
real-life mermaids
there are plenty of people out there who
want to become one and you could become
a sea creature too if you wanted to
Cyclops in Greek literature Cyclops are
one-eyed Giants who are part of
different stories in Homer's Odyssey
they were portrayed of cannibals who
lived in a distant land when the hero
and his men found a cave filled with
food they were quickly surprised by a
giant who trapped them and ate many of
the men to make sure that he wouldn't be
the next one to end up his stomach
Odysseus gave him some wine when the
giant was drunk the hero told him his
name was nobody made him blind and heard
the Cyclops screaming that nobody heard
him and this is how he got the chance to
escape
but once you see a Cyclops in real life
you won't want to run away from it just
look at this beautiful goat with one eye
no one thought that it would survive but
after a week this precious creature was
still alive and walking on its fore feet
but this is not the first time that we
see some
this this rare condition is called
cyclopia which is characterized by the
brain failing to develop into two
hemispheres this is why the skull forms
only one eye socket it can happen in
humans too but unfortunately there is no
happy ending we believe that ancient
Greeks could have seen it in the past
and used it as an inspiration for their
stories the Olympics in ancient time the
Olympics were not only a competition but
they were also associated with a myth
3000 years ago Zeus the father of the
Greek gods fought and defeated his
father for the control of the world when
he won a temple and a statue were built
for him in the valley called Olympia his
son Heracles then decided to become the
founder of the games and the religious
festivals in the city and his honor held
every four years during the summer male
citizens from everywhere in Greece came
to the city to face the competition and
the most popular games in the country at
that time the foot race was the only
event but over the decades more
activities were added like wrestling the
pentathlon and the javelin throw one
funny thing to know is that the men were
competing naked at that time and there
was nothing to be ashamed of but a lot
of things have changed since then
including the clothes the Olympic Games
disappeared in the middle of the second
century BC when Greece lost its
independence to Rome but they came back
centuries later when Pierre de Coubertin
decided to revive the Olympic Games in
1896
since that day athletes from all around
the world are competing and what has
become the most popular games in human
history
Ikaros men have always wanted to fly and
this is probably what inspired this myth
Icarus was the son of a man who created
the labyrinth that was used to trap the
Minotaur but to keep this secret safe he
and his father were imprisoned in a
tower above King Minos palace the two
men found a way to escape by creating
two sets of wings that were made with
feathers glued together with wax they
were surprisingly able to fly away but
Icarus didn't listen to his father when
he told him not to fly too high this is
how the Sun melted the wax and Icarus
fell into the sea we now know that this
story is impossible but not for the
reason that you might think the Sun is
so far that flying a little higher can't
do any damage to the wing unless someone
finds a way to fly up into space but
when it comes to flying with wings a man
recently proved that it was possible
gentlemen Yves Rossy loves flying in the
sky in Dubai like a superhero at a speed
of up to 125 miles per hour
we still
believe that found a way to realize
every man's dream and this time we're
pretty sure that the seven-foot wingspan
belt prophesies when you can't
understand something you find meaning
anywhere around you and this is where
these strange myths come from Greeks
relied on Oracle's to make important
decisions and also use the science of
omens to read the future but one of the
most important things anyone could learn
from was their dreams which they
believed was a message sent from the
gods there were three types of dreams
that could be significant some of them
were a literal vision of what could
occur others required symbolic
interpretation and the last ones were a
visit from friends ghosts or even gods
Homer's Odyssey was a great example of
this as soon Ella P dreamed up an eagle
getting rid of 50s while she was waiting
for her husband to return home from war
she later realized that it was symbolic
of Odysseus coming back after getting
rid of the suitors but what about dreams
nowadays we still don't really
understand them but many people think
that they actually have a meaning they
won't tell you what will happen next
week but they can use your past to make
you move forward in the future for
example if you experience trauma you
will probably have dreams associated
with it by getting used to this source
of stress you will feel better when you
experience something similar and that's
why any reason is good to have a good
night of sleep the Trojan horse if you
thought that this adventure was part of
history you'll be disappointed to hear
that it is mostly a myth in Homer's poem
The Iliad Prince Paris of Troy stole
Helen from her husband King Menelaus
this is why he decided to besiege the
city for ten years hoping to get her
back after many heroes had passed away
they knew that they had to find a better
way to win the war
they gave the Trojans a giant wooden
horse as an offering to the goddess
Athena the Trojans dragged the horse
within Troy but they weren't prepared
for what was going to happen next they
were attacked by the men hiding in the
horse and this is how the Greek warriors
won the war however even though evidence
shows that Troy did burn down during the
war there is no proof that the giant
horse ever existed Homer wrote the poem
several hundred years after the war took
place so it was impossible for him to
know what really happened no matter what
the myth is so popular that we still
talk about the Trojan horse nowadays but
in the 21st century it now means
something else this is now what we call
computer codes that look like legitimate
applications but that are actually used
to steal personal information who knew
that the Trojan War was still happening
nowadays
hiss this is probably one of the most
famous tragedies of all time and we're
still reading at thousands of years
after in this story
an Oracle told King Laius and his wife
Jocasta that their son was a threat so
they decided to give him away
Oedipus never met his parents and was
raised by a shepherd when an Oracle told
him that he was going to do something
terrible to his parents he decided to
leave his family not knowing that he was
actually adopted this is what didn't
stop him from accidentally getting rid
of his biological father defeating
Spinks marrying his mother and becoming
King of Thieves all the prophecies were
true after all
and when Oedipus realized what happened
we didn't have the chance to see a happy
ending which is probably why it's called
a tragedy this story was so popular that
the name of the hero is still used today
in modern psychology the Oedipus complex
describes a young boy who falls in love
with his mother but can't stand his
father Sigmund Freud thought that it was
a crucial stage in the normal
development process of a child around
the age of 3 or 5 not everyone agrees
with this theory but this is still proof
that we won't be forgetting what
happened thousands of years ago Scylla
in off its metamorphosis this character
was believed to be a beautiful woman a
man fell in love with her and asked
Circe for a love potion to win her the
sorceress fell in love with him and
decided to turn Scylla into a monster to
get rid of the competition in Homer's
Odyssey Scylla was an immortal and
irresistible sea monster with 12 feet
and six heads with the triple row of
shark-like teeth
she ate anything that stood in her way
including six of Odysseus's men it
didn't take too long for the hero to
navigate past her and this memory will
probably stay in his head forever but
did you know that you can still see
monsters like this in real life they
don't have six heads but we think that
two is already really impressive the
two-headed snake shares one body but
they both have different personalities
one is more aggressive than the other
and even physically attacks the other
head Polly Stephanie is the biological
term for having many heads it is rare in
humans but it is more common among
reptiles Aristotle even found one in 350
BC so it is possible that Homer used it
as an inspiration so yes you might see a
two-headed monster one day if you're
lucky but we don't think that it's going
to eat you the music humans have been
interested in beautiful sound since they
have been able to recreate them and in
ancient Greece they even thought that it
was a gift from the gods
muses were entertaining
the gods with their singing dancing and
music Dionysus the god of wine was
associated with this art and the
invention of many instruments was also
attributed to different gods most Greeks
knew how to play music which was used as
a way to worship the ancient gods this
is why philosophers started studying
music and the followers of Pythagoras
even believed that it was a mathematical
expression of the cosmic order at that
time people thought that music could
even cure mental and physical illnesses
they also believed that it could have an
emotional and moral effect on the
listener and their soul this is my some
instruments where bands and complicated
rhythms and music were considered
morally dangerous to anyone who listened
to it and it's in the 21st century that
we can finally say they were right music
can actually improve our health in many
ways it can reduce stress and anxiety
improve memory decrease pain improve
immune functioning and help us exercise
but don't worry we won't ban it anytime
soon if music is really a gift from the
gods we want to use it as much as we can
Medusa this creature was one of the most
terrifying women who ever existed she
were snakes on her head at the
punishment from goddess Athena Medusa
was so hideous that anyone who looked at
her would be turned into stone it seemed
impossible to stop her and this is why
Polydectes asked Perseus to come back
with her head thinking that he would
easily get rid of him the hero was
finally able to do it by using a
reflected bronze shield that Athena gave
to him
Perseus then escaped and when came back
home used Medusa's head to turn
Polydectes and his court into stone you
might think that this story is nothing
but a myth and don't worry we won't show
you a woman with snakes on her head but
you will be surprised to learn that
something can actually end your life
just by looking at it it is the
Chernobyl's elephants foot also
nicknamed the real-life Medusa after a
disaster in the nuclear power plant in
1986 the core of the reactor began to
melt and created a lava like substance
that was called the elephant's foot for
its wrinkled appearance the radiation
level was so high that anyone who looked
at it for more than 300 seconds would
pass away two days later and this
substance will stay radioactive for the
next hundred thousand years when we
think about this we think that we prefer
a woman with snakes on her head what is
your favorite story from Greek mythology
don't be shy to tell us what it is in
the comment section down below and
that's it pretend ancient Greek myths
that turned out to be true for more
stories like this
make sure you watch 10 amazing pictures
they won't show you in history books
thanks for watching
[Music]